FOR HALLOWEEN.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
LET'S SAY YOU ARE RUNNING
PRESIDENT AND YOU'RE ALREADY UP
FOR FELONS VOTING.
WELL, CHAMP, WHICH ONES?
CUTE ONES, VEGANS, REGISTERED
DEMOCRATS?
THE ANSWER, THIS GUY IS A LIMIT.
>> DOES THIS MEAN THAT YOU WOULD
SUPPORT IN FRANCHISING PEOPLE
LIKE THE BOSTON MARATHON BOMBER,
A CONVICTED TERRORIST AND
MURDERER?
>> IF SOMEBODY COMMITS A SERIOUS
CRIME, SEXUAL ASSAULT, MURDER,
THEY ARE GOING TO PUNISHED.
I THINK THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS
INHERENT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
YES, EVEN FOR TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
>> PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED IN
PRISON, LIKE THE BOSTON MARATHON
BOMBER, ON DEATH ROW, PEOPLE
CONVICTED OF SEXUAL ASSAULT,
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
GREAT ANSWER.
DAYS AFTER TERRORISTS MURDERED
MEN, WOMEN, AND CHILDREN,
DEMOCRATS TACKLE STUFF THAT
TRULY MATTERS.
CAN TERRORISTS STILL VOTE?
TALK ABOUT DAMNING YOUR OWN
PARTY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO'VE LOST
THEIR VOTING RIGHTS FOREVER.
CRYSTAL CAMPBELL, MARK RICHARD,
LOU LINDSAY, SEAN COLLIER.
THEY CAN VOTE.
THE BOSTON BOMBER SUPPRESSED
THEIRS PERMANENTLY.
THESE CANDIDATES ALSO MISS THE
POINT OF INCARCERATION.
IF YOU JUST JOINING US FROM CNN,
THIS MAY SHOCK YOU.
WHEN YOU'RE IN PRISON, YOU LOSE
RIGHTS.
IT'S CALLED PRISON, NOT
SPRING BREAK.
IT'S NOT A SLIPPERY SLOPE WHEN
DENYING VOTING RIGHTS BECAUSE
THE SLOPE DOESN'T ACTUALLY
EXIST.
YOU ARE IN JAIL.
THERE IS NO FREEDOM.
YOU CAN EVEN VOTE WITH YOUR
FEET.
IN A SOCIALIST MIND, SINCE
DOESN'T APPLY.
SOCIALISTS DISGUISE THEIR THIRST
FOR POWER IS THE GREATER GOOD
WHICH MEANS PRETENDING TO CARE
WHILE TAKING CONTROL, SO IT'S
NOT ABOUT HELPING THOSE IN JAIL,
JUST EXPANDING THE JAIL TO
INCLUDE YOU AND ME.
CUBA, VENEZUELA, NORTH KOREA,
USSR.
WHAT MADE THEM UNIQUE, EVERY
CITIZEN WAS A PRISONER AND EVERY
SOCIALIST POLITICIAN THE JAILER.
WHICH IS WHY THIS SOCIALISM
THING IT REALLY ONLY WORKS FOR
BERNIE.
THE REST OF US SERVE THE
SENTENCE.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN, HERE'S MY
THEORY.
I ALMOST SAID THERAPY.
[LAUGHTER]
THIS IS MY THERAPY.
ASKING YOU THIS QUESTION.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE THING.
YOU SHOULD COME TO ME AS YOUR
THERAPIST.
>> Greg: LET'S PRETEND.
DR. WILLIAMS, I HAVE THIS
PROBLEM.
I KEEP THINKING THAT BERNIE
WANTS FELONS TO VOTE BECAUSE HE
KNOWS THAT THEY WILL VOTE
DEMOCRAT.
>> Juan: IS THAT RIGHT?
THAT'S WHAT REPUBLICANS THINK.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Jesse: STUDIES SHOW
REPUBLICANS ARE NOT GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM FELONS VOTING.
>> Juan: SEEMS THAT
REPUBLICANS IN FLORIDA VOTED TO
ALLOW FELONS, ONCE THEY LEAVE
PRISON -- MUST BE FOR ONCE THEY
LEAVE, THAT'S DIFFERENT.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
KAMALA HARRIS WAS SHE'S OKAY
WITH ONCE THEY LEAVE PRISON.
GOT TO MAKE THAT DISTINCTION.
BUT BERNIE IS SAYING IN PRISON.
>> Greg: THIS REALLY WAS,
JUAN, THIS IS LIKE THE KILL SHOT
THAT THEY GAVE DUKAKIS.
REMEMBER BERNARD SHAW?
THE " --
IF SOMEBODY RAPED AND MURDERED
YOUR WIFE, WOULD YOU STILL BE
AGAINST THE DEATH PENALTY AND
DUKAKIS SAID YES.
>> Juan: ANYBODY WHO WOULD DO
DAMAGE TO YOU, MY FRIENDS, MY
FAMILY.
OBVIOUSLY EMOTION.
I WANT TO CHOKE THAT'S ON
ABOUT...
I THINK BERNIE IS BEING SINCERE
HERE AND I TELL YOU WHY.
IF YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO BEEN
IN PRISON, THERE IS A SENTIMENT
AND I THINK IT CROSSES CLINICAL
PARTIES THAT SAYS THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE TO BE REENTERED INTO
SOCIETY.
>> Greg: I AM ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> Juan: OKAY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING AND
JOBS, IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WELFARE, YOU SAY THAT GUY
COMMITTED A FELONY.
HE CAN'T REENTER SOCIETY.
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
GOING TO BE A HIGH LEVEL OF
PEOPLE GOING BACK TO CRIME.
>> Greg: YOU ARE A TERRIBLE
THERAPIST.
I CAME TO YOU WITH THE PROBLEM
AND YOU SOLVED -- YOU ARE GOING,
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS OTHER
PROBLEM.
I HAVE NIGHT TERRORS.
JESSE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
KEEP IT SEPARATE, WHAT'S HIS
FACE, WHAT'S HIS NAME AGAIN?
BERNIE.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE IN
JAIL, TERRORISTS.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS WANT
TERRORISTS TO VOTE.
THINK ABOUT THAT, GREG.
THEY JUST HANDLED DONALD TRUMP
THE WEDGE USED OF WEDGE ISSUES.
JUAN, I HAVE A QUESTION.
ARE DEMOCRATS TRYING TO LOSE THE
ELECTION.
MADE TO ORDER FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS WILLIE HORTON 2.0.
>> Juan: YOU THINK WILLIE
HORTON IS GOOD NEWS?
OKAY.
>> Jesse: THIS IS WHAT IT'S
LIKE.
THEY HAVE TOTALLY UNDERCUT THEIR
WHOLE MESSAGING ON ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING THE
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
HACK THE DEMOCRACY.
THEN THEY WANT TO SET UP VOTING
BOOTHS ON DEATH ROW.
I WONDER IF THERE'S EVER GOING
TO BE ANY CORRUPTION OR FRAUD
WITH THE VOTING PROCESS IN
PRISON WHEN YOU HAVE GUARDS WITH
BATONS LOOKING DOWN ON GUYS
FILLING OUT THEIR BALLOTS.
IT'S THE MOST RIDICULOUS THING
I'VE EVER SEEN AND THE REASON
THEY ARE DOING THIS, JUAN, IS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PERSUADE
ENOUGH ACTUAL VOTERS ABOUT THEIR
IDEAS SO THEY HAVE TO CREATE NEW
VOTERS.
THEY GOT ROCKED IN 2016, SO
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO CHANGE
THEIR MESSAGE, THEY ARE JUST
TRYING TO CHANGE THE RULES.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DID WITH THE
SUPREME COURT EXPANSION.
THIS IS THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
ALL OVER AGAIN.
DO YOU THINK PEDOPHILES VOTING
OR SERIAL RAPISTS VOTING IS
GOING TO PLAY IN IOWA?
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS, SECONDMENT RIGHTS BUT
THEY WANT TO GIVE VOTING RIGHTS
TO TERRORISTS.
>> Juan: ARE YOU OKAY?
>> Jesse: I'M GREAT.
>> Greg: EMILY.
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS GOT MORE
VOTES THAN THE REPUBLICANS IN
2016.
>> Jesse: NOT IN THE RIGHT
STATES.
>> Greg: ALL OF THEM WERE
FELONS OR AT LEAST LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AM FROM CALIFORNIA.
EMILY, YOU CLAIM TO BE A LAWYER.
>> Emily: YES.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> Emily: I FEEL SO STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS.
LET'S KEEP IT TO THE MOMENT TO
THE PRESENTLY INCARCERATED.
YOU MAKE GREAT POINTS.
6 MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR THAT HER
POST-CONVICTION FELONS.
I THINK IT RAISES A LOT OF GREAT
QUESTIONS.
WHY DO WE CONDEMN OUR
INCARCERATED TO CIVIC --
WHY DO WE TAKE AWAY THEIR RIGHT
TO VOTE?
WHY DO WE SUPPORT A PRISON-BASED
GERRYMANDERING WHEN PEOPLE
INCARCERATED ARE COUNTED IN THE
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT WHAT
BERNIE IS TALKING ABOUT.
BERNIE IS TALKING ABOUT LETTING
A TERRORIST VOTE WHILE HE'S IN
JAIL.
>> Juan: HE IS A CITIZEN STILL
STILL.
>> Greg: HE IS IN PRISON.
>> Emily: I WANT TO DRAW THE
DISTINCTION THAT YOU CAN
ABSOLUTELY DISTINGUISH VIOLENT
CRIME, CONVICTS AND WHEN YOU
REDUCE IT TO THE TINY PERCENTAGE
OF THE SERIAL RAPIST AND
BOMBERS, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BUT TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
INCARCERATED, A BIPARTISAN
COMMITMENT TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, WHO BETTER TO
PARTICIPATE POTENTIALLY THAN
THOSE PRESENTLY INCARCERATED
IS IT THE 3/5 CONSTITUTIONAL
CLAUSE ALL OVER AGAIN?
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE A LOUSY
ARGUMENT, EMILY.
>> Dana: I THINK WE ARE
MISSING ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS LAST NIGHT, AND
THAT IS THAT BERNIE, YES, HE
SAID THAT.
THAT WAS HIS INSTINCT.
DON'T THINK THEY WERE
ANTICIPATING THE QUESTION.
MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG HAD A
DIFFERENT ANSWER.
>> Greg: WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HEAR IT?
>> Dana: YES, PLEASE.
>> Greg: LET'S PLAY THAT TAPE
FOR DANA.
>> PART OF THE PUNISHMENT WHEN
YOU'RE CONVICTED OF A CRIME IN
YOUR INCARCERATED IS, YOU LOSE
CERTAIN RIGHTS.
YOU LOSE YOUR FREEDOM.
I THINK DURING THAT PERIOD, IT
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE TO HAVE AN
EXCEPTION FOR THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> AND PEOPLE LEAVE THE PRISON
SYSTEM, THEY NEED TO BE
REINTEGRATED INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET A JOB, TO BE ABLE
TO FIND DECENT HOUSING, AND THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS, THAT
MEANS THEY NEED THE RIGHT TO
VOTE TO BE REINSTATED.
>> Dana: ELIZABETH WARREN, SHE
IS TRYING TO SOLVE A DIFFERENT
PROBLEM AND THAT'S THAT AFTER
YOU'VE SERVED YOUR DEBT TO
SOCIETY.
IF WE BELIEVE THAT VOTING IS A
PRIVILEGE OF YOUR CITIZENSHIP,
THERE HAS TO BE SOME SORT OF
PUNISHMENT FOR COMMITTING A
CRIME.
IN FLORIDA, THERE WERE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS THAT VOTED FOR
RESTORING VOTING RIGHTS TO
FELONS.
THEY MADE A COUPLE EXCEPTIONS
FOR VIOLENT CRIME AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT BUT THAT'S
TOTALLY DIFFERENT FROM PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO VOTE IN PRISON.
I THINK MAYOR PETE HAD A MUCH
BETTER ANSWER THAN BERNIE LAST
NIGHT.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT WIFE
MAYOR PETE IS RISING, BUT
BECAUSE HE'S NOT CRAZY.
>> Emily: IS IT A PRIVILEGE OR
AS A RIGHT?
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT?
>> Juan: IT IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Jesse: IF YOU ARE A
TERRORIST AND YOU BOMB CIVILIAN
CIVILIANS.
>> Greg: I DON'T MIND TAKING
THAT RIGHT OR PRIVILEGE TAKEN
AWAY.
THEY ARE IN A BOX.
DO YOU THINK THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT VOTING?
THEY ALREADY CAN'T LEAVE.
I DON'T SEE -- WE ARE ARGUING
OVER SOMETHING SO STUPID.
>> Emily: I SPENT A LOT OF
TIME WITH INMATES AND THEY DO
CARE.
I THINK THAT'S WHY, THOSE
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THEY MIGHT
TURN TOWARDS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I DO FEEL LIKE A LOT OF THEM
BASED ON THEIR EXPERIENCE ARE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY FOR LIMITED
GOVERNMENT AND LIMITED
OVERREACH.
THEY ARE RECEIVING THE BRUNT OF
IT.
>> Greg: NOW YOU CHANGED MY